The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, we're
all ready to go.
This is Discrete Stochastic
Processes as you are know.
It is--
want to get it where
I can read it, too.
We're going to try to deal
with a bunch of different
topics today, some of which are
a little bit philosophical
saying, what is probability
really?
You are supposed to have taken
a course in probability, but
unfortunately courses in
probability are almost always
courses in how to solve
well-posed problems.
The big problem in probability
theory, and particularly
stochastic processes is not
so much how do you solve
well-posed problems.
Anybody can do that.
Or anybody who has a little bit
of background can do it.
The hard problem is finding
the right models for a
real-world problem.
I will call these real-world
problems.
I hate people who call things
real-world because they sound
like they dislike theory
or something.
It's the only word I can think
of though, because physical
world is no longer adequate
because so much of the
applications of probability are
to all sorts of different
things, not having to do with
the physical world very much,
but having to do with things
like the business world, or
the economic world, or the
biological world, or all of
these things.
So real-world is just a code
word we'll use to distinguish
theory from anything real that
you might have to deal with.
Theory is very nice
because theory--
everything is specified.
There's a right answer
to everything.
There is a wrong
answer usually.
But there's at least
one right answer.
And most of us like those
things because
they're very specific.
People go into engineering and
science very often because
they don't like the
uncertainty of a
lot of other fields.
The problem is as soon as you
go into probability theory,
you're moving away from that
safe region where everything
is specified, and you're moving
into a region where
things, in fact, are not very
well-specified and you have to
be careful about it.
OK, so first we're going to talk
about probability in the
real world and probability as
a branch of mathematics.
Then we're going to
say what discrete
stochastic processes are.
Then we're going to talk just a
very, very little bit about
the processes we're
going to study.
If you want to see more
of that, you have two
chapters of the notes.
You can look at them.
You can look at the
table of contents.
And more than that, if you look
at my website, you will
see the notes for all the other
chapters if you want to
read ahead or if you want to
really find out what kinds of
things we're going to talk about
and what kinds of things
we're not going to talk about.
Then we're going to talk
about when, where,
and how is this useful?
The short answer to that is
it's useful everywhere.
But we'll have to
see why that is.
Then we're going to talk
about the axioms
of probability theory.
You cannot take any elementary
course in probability, or even
in statistics, without seeing
the axioms of probability.
And in almost all of those
cases, and in almost all of
the graduate courses I've
seen, you see them, they
disappear, and suddenly you're
solving problems in whatever
way you can, and the
axioms have nothing
to do with it anymore.
So we're going to see that, in
fact, the axioms do have
something to do with this.
Those of you who want to be
real engineers and not
mathematicians, you'll
find this a little
uncomfortable at times.
We are going to be
proving things.
And you will have to
get used to that.
And I'll try to convince you
of why it's important to be
able to prove things.
Then we're going on to a
review of probability,
independent events,
experiments, and random variables.
So that's what we'll do today.
Incidentally, this course
started about--
must've been 25 years
ago or so.
I started it because we had a
huge number of students at MIT
who had been interested in
communication and control, and
who were suddenly starting to
get interested in networks.
And there were all sorts of
queuing problems that they had
to deal with every day.
And they started to read
about queuing theory.
and it was the most disjointed,
crazy theory in
the world where there were
1,000 different kinds of
queues and each one
of them had to be
treated in its own way.
And we realized that stochastic
processes was the
right way to tie all of
that together, so we
started this course.
And we made it mostly discrete
so it would deal primarily
with network type
applications.
As things have grown, it now
deals with a whole lot more
applications.
And we'll see how that
works later on.
OK, how did probability get
started in the real world?
Well, there were games of chance
that everybody was
interested in.
People really like to gamble.
I don't know why.
I don't like to gamble
that much.
I would rather be certain
about things.
But most people love
to gamble.
And most people have an
intuitive sense of what
probability is about.
I mean, eight-year-old kids,
when they start to learn to
play games of chance--
and there are all sorts
of board games
that involve chance.
These kids, if they're
bright--
and I'm sure you people fall
into that category--
they immediately start to figure
out what the odds are.
I mean, how many of you have
never thought about what the
odds are in some
gambling game?
OK, that makes my point.
So all of you understand this
at an intuitive level.
But what makes games of chance
easier to deal with than all
the other issues where we have
uncertainty in life?
Well, games of chance are
inherently repeatable.
You play a game of chance and
you play many, many hands, or
many, many throws, or
many, many trials.
And after many, many trials of
what's essentially the same
experiment, you start to get
a sense of what relative
frequencies are.
You start to get a sense of what
the odds are because of
doing this repeatedly.
So games of chance are easy to
use probability on because
they are repeatable.
You have essentially the same
thing going on each time, but
each time there's a
different answer.
You flip a coin and sometimes
it comes up heads and
sometimes it comes up tails.
So in fact, we have to figure
out how to deal with that fact
that there is uncertainty
there.
I'll talk about that in
just another minute.
But anyway, most of life's
decisions involve uncertainty.
I mean, for all of you, when you
go into a PhD program, you
have two problems.
Am I going to enjoy this?
And you don't know whether
you're going to enjoy it
because not until you really
get into it do you have a
sense of whether this set of
problems you're dealing with
is something that you
like to deal with.
And the only way you can do
that is to make guesses.
You come up with likelihoods.
There's some likelihood.
There's a risk cost-benefit
that you deal with.
And in life, risk cost-benefits
are always based
on some sense of what the
likelihood of something is.
Now, what is a likelihood?
A likelihood is just
a probability.
It's a synonym for
probability.
When you get into the
mathematics of probability,
likelihood has a special
meaning to it.
But in the real world,
likelihood is just a word you
use when you don't want to let
people know that you're really
talking about probabilities.
OK, so that's where we are.
But on the last slide, you saw
the word "essentially,
essentially, essentially." If
you read the notes, and I hope
you read the notes, because I
spent the last three years
doing virtually nothing
but trying to
make these notes clear.
I would appreciate it if any
of you, with whatever
background you have, when you
read these nodes, if you read
them twice and you still don't
understand something, tell me
you don't understand it.
If you know why you don't
understand it, I'd appreciate
it knowing that.
But just saying "help" is enough
to let me know that I
still haven't made something
as clear as it should be.
At least as clear as it should
be for some of the people who
I think should be taking
this course.
One of the problems we have at
MIT now, and at every graduate
school in the world I think,
is that human knowledge has
changed and grown so much
in the last 50 years.
So when you study something
general, like probability,
there's just an enormous
mass of stuff you
have to deal with.
And because of that, when you
try to write notes for a
course, you don't know
what anybody's
background is anymore.
I mean, it used to be that when
you saw a graduate course
at MIT, people would know
what limits were.
People would know what basic
mathematics is all about.
They would know what
continuity means.
They would know some
linear algebra.
They would know all sorts
of different things.
Many people still do
know those things.
Many other people have studied
all sorts of other fascinating
and very interesting things.
They're just as smart, but they
have a very different
background.
So if your background is
different, it's not your fault
that you don't have the kind
of background that makes
probability easy.
Just yell.
Or yell in class.
Please ask questions.
The fact that we're videotaping
this makes it far
more interesting for anybody
who's using OpenCourseWare to
see some kinds of questions
going on, so I very much
encourage that.
I'm fairly old at this point,
and my memory is getting shot.
So if you ask a question and I
don't remember what it's all
about, just be patient
with it.
I will come back the next time,
or I'll send you an
email straightening it out.
But I will often get confused
doing something, and that's
just because of my age.
It's what we call "senior
moments." It's not that I
don't understand the subject.
I think I understand it, I just
don't remember it anymore.
Important point about
probability.
Think about flipping a coin.
I'm going to talk about
flipping coins a
great deal this term.
It's an absolutely trivial
topic, but it's important
because when you understand
deep things about a large
subject, the best way to
understand them is to
understand them in terms of the
most trivial examples you
can think of.
Now, when you flip a coin, the
outcome-- heads or tails--
really depends on the initial
velocity, the orientation of
the person flipping it, or the
machine flipping it, the coin
surfaces, the ground surface.
And after you put all of those
things into a careful
equation, you will know whether
the coin is going to
come up heads or tails.
I don't think quantum theory
has anything to do with
something as big as a coin.
I might be wrong.
I've never looked into it.
And frankly, I don't care.
Because the point that I'm
trying to make is that
flipping a coin, and many of
the things that you view as
random, when you look at them
in a slightly different way,
are not random.
There's a big field in
communication called data
compression.
And data compression is based on
random models for the data,
which is going to
be compressed.
Now, what I'm saying here today
is by no means random.
Or maybe it is partly random.
Maybe it's coming out of a
random mind, I don't know.
But all of the data we try to
compress to the people who
have created that data, it's
not random at all.
If you study the data
carefully enough--
I mean, code breakers and people
like that are extremely
good at sorting out what the
meaning is in something, which
cannot be done by data
compression techniques at all.
So the point is, when you're
doing data compression, you
model the data as being random
and having certain
characteristics.
But it really isn't.
So the model is no good.
When you get to more important
questions--
well, data compression is
an important question.
When you ask, what's the
probability of another
catastrophic oil spill
in the next year?
Or you ask the question, what's
the probability that
Google stock will double
in five years?
That's less important,
but it's still
important to many people.
How do you model that?
Understanding probability
theory, understanding all the
mathematics of this is not going
to help you model this.
Now, why do I make such
a big deal about this?
Well, there have been a number
of times in the last 10 or 15
years when the whole financial
system of the world has almost
been destroyed by very,
very bright PhDs.
Many of them coming from
electrical engineering.
Most of whom are really
superb at
understanding probability theory.
And they have used their
probability theory to analyze
risk and other things
in investments.
And what has happened?
They do very well for a while.
Suddenly they do so well that
they think they can borrow all
sorts of money and risk other
people's money as
well as their own.
In fact, they try to do that
right from the beginning.
And then suddenly, the whole
thing collapses.
Because their models
are no damn good.
There's nothing wrong with their
mathematics, it's that
their models are no good.
So please, especially if you're
going to do something
important in your lives--
if you're just going to write
papers in engineering
journals, maybe it's
all right.
But if you're going to make
decisions about things, please
spend some time thinking about
the probability models that
you come up because this
is vitally important.
OK, what's probability?
It's a branch of mathematics.
Now we're into something
that's more familiar,
something that's simpler,
something we can deal with.
You might be uncomfortable
with what
probability really means.
And all probability books, all
stochastic process books are
uncomfortable with this.
Feller is the best book
in probability
there's ever been written.
Any question you have, he
probably has the answer to it.
When you look at what he says
about real-world probability,
the modeling issues, he's an
extraordinarily bright guy.
And he spent some time
thinking about this.
But you read it and you realize
that it's pure nonsense.
So please, take my
word for it.
Don't assume that real-world
probability is something
you're going to learn about from
other people because you
can't trust what any
of them say.
It's something you have to think
through for yourselves,
and we'll talk more about
this as we go.
But now, when we get into
mathematics, that's fine.
We just create models.
And once we have the model,
we just use it.
We have standard models for
all sorts of different
standard problems.
When you talk about coin
tossing, what almost everyone
means is not this crazy thing I
was just talking about where
you have an initial angular
momentum when you flip a coin
and all of that stuff.
It's a purely mathematical model
where a coin is flipped
and with probability one half
it comes up heads and with
probability one half
it comes up tails.
OK, students are given a
well-specified model, and they
calculate various things.
This is in mathematical
probability.
Heads and tails are equiprobable
in that system.
Subsequent tosses
are independent.
Here's a little bit
of cynicism.
I apologize for insulting
you people with it.
I apologize to any faculty
member who later reads this.
And I particularly apologize to
businessmen and government
people who might read it.
Students compute, professors
write papers, business and
government leaders obtain
questionable models and data
on which they can
blame failures.
Most cynical towards business
leaders because business
leaders often hire
consultants.
Not so much to learn what to do,
but so they have excuses
when what they do doesn't
work out right.
When I say the students compute,
what I mean is this
in almost all the courses you've
taken up until now--
and in this course also--
what you're going
to be doing is
solving well-posed problems.
You solve well-posed exercises
because that's a good way to
understand what the
mathematics of
the subject is about.
Don't think that that's
the only part of it.
If that's the only thing you're
doing, you might as
well not waste your time.
You might as well do
something else.
You might as well go out and
shovel snow today instead of
trying to learn about
probability theory.
It's more pleasant to learn
about probability theory.
OK, the use of probability
models has two major
problems with it.
The first problem is, how do
you make a model for a
real-world problem?
And a partial answer is, learn
about estimation and decisions
in the context of
standard models.
In other words, decisions and
estimation inside a completely
mathematical framework.
Then you learn a great
deal about the
real-world problem itself.
Not about the mathematics of it,
but about how you actually
understand what's going on.
If you talk to somebody
who is a superb
architect in any field--
networks, computer systems,
control systems, anything--
what are you going to find?
You're not going to find huge,
involved sets of equations
that they're going to use to
explain something to you.
They're going to pick at-- if
there any good, they're going
to take this big problem, and
they're going to take your
issue with this big problem.
And they're going to find the
one or two really important
things that tell you something
that you have to know.
And that's what you want to
get out of this course.
You want to get the ability to
take all of the chat, put it
all together, and be able to
say one or two important
things which is really
necessary.
That's where you're going to.
Before you get there, you'll
take low-level jobs in various
companies and you'll compute
a lot of things.
You'll simulate a
lot of things.
You'll deal with a
lot of detail.
Eventually, you're going to get
to the point where you've
got to make major decisions.
And you want to be
ready for it.
OK, that's enough philosophy.
I will try to give no more
philosophy today, except when
I get pushed into it.
OK, one of the problems in this
problem of finding a good
model is that no model
is perfect.
Namely, what happens is you
keep finding more and more
complicated models, which
deal with more
and more of the issues.
And as you deal with them,
things get more complicated.
You're more down in the
level of details and
you're finding out less.
So you want to find some sort of
match between a model that
tells you something and a model
which is complicated
enough to deal with
the issues.
There's a beautiful quote by
Alfred North Whitehead.
I don't know whether you've
ever heard of Whitehead.
You've probably heard of
Bertrand Russell, who was both
a great logician and a great
philosopher, and had a lot to
do with the origins
of set theory.
Whitehead and Russell together,
wrote this massive
book around the turn of the last
century between the 1900s
and the 2000s called Principia
Mathematica where they try to
resolve all of the paradoxes
which were coming up in
mathematics.
And Whitehead's general
philosophical comment was,
"Seek simplicity and
distrust it."
Now, every time I look at
that, I say, why in hell
didn't he say, seek simplicity
and question it?
I mean, you all hear about
questioning authority, of
course, and that's
important to do.
Why when you find a simple model
for something should you
distrust it?
Well, the reason is
psychological.
If you find a simple model for
something and you question it,
you have an enormous
psychological bias towards not
giving up the simple model.
You want to keep that
simple model.
And therefore, it takes an
enormous amount of evidence
before you're going to
give something out.
Whitehead said something
more than that.
He said, "Seek simplicity
and distrust it."
Now, why do I talk about the
philosophy of science when
we're trying to learn about
probability theory?
Well, probability theory is
a mathematical theory.
It's the basis for a great
deal of science.
And it's the place where
modeling is most difficult.
Scientific questions in most
areas, if there's no
probability or uncertainty
involved, you just do an
experiment that tells
you the answer.
You might not do it carefully
enough and then 10 other
people do it.
And finally, everybody
agrees, this is the
answer to that problem.
In probability, it ain't
that simple.
And that's why one has to focus
on this a little more
than usual.
The second problem is, how do
you make a probability model
that has no hidden
paradoxes in it?
In other words, when you make
a mathematical model, how do
you make sure that it really
is well-posed?
How do you make sure that when
you solve a problem in that
mathematical model that you
don't come to something that
doesn't make any sense?
Well, everyone's answer to that
is you use Kolmogorov's
axioms of probability.
Because back in 1933, Kolmogorov
published this
little thin book.
Those of you who are interested
in the history of
science probably ought
to read it.
You will find you only
understand the first five
pages the first time
you look at it.
But it's worthwhile doing that
because here was one of the
truly great minds of the
early 20th century.
And he took everything he knew
about probability, which was a
whole lot more than I know
certainly, and a whole lot
more than anybody else at the
time knew, and he collapsed it
into these very simple axioms.
And he said, if you obey these
axioms in a model that you use
in probability, those axioms
will keep you out of any
paradoxes at all.
And then, he showed why that
was and he showed how the
axioms could be used
and so forth.
So we're going to spend a little
bit of time talking
about them today.
OK, quickly, what is a discrete
stochastic process?
Well, a stochastic process--
you've been talking
about probability.
And you might be getting the
idea that I'm just using the
name "stochastic processes" as
a foil for talking about what
I really love, which
is the probability.
And there's a certain amount
of truth to that.
But stochastic processes are
special types of probability
models where the sample points
represent functions in time.
In other words, when we're
dealing with a probability
model, the basis of
a probability
model is a sample space.
It's the set of possible things
that might happen.
And you can reduce that to the
sample points, which are the
indivisible, little, tiny crumbs
of what happens when
you do an experiment.
It's the thing which specifies
everything that can be
specified in that model
of that experiment.
OK, when you get to a stochastic
process, what
you're doing is you're looking
at a situation in which these
sample points, the solutions to
what happens is, in fact, a
whole sequence of random
variables in time.
And what that means is instead
of looking at just a vector of
random variables, you're going
to be looking at a whole
sequence of random variables.
Now, what is different about a
vector of a very large number
of random variables
and an infinite
sequence of random variables?
Well, from an engineering
standpoint, not very much.
I mean, there's nothing you can
do to actually look at an
infinite sequence of
random variables.
If you start out at the Big Bang
and you carry it on to
what you might imagine is the
time when the sun explodes or
something, that's a finite
amount of time.
And if you imagine how fast
you can observe things,
there's a finite number
of random
variables you might observe.
All these models we're going to
be dealing with get outside
or that realm, and they deal
with something that starts
infinitely far in the
past and goes
infinitely far in the future.
It doesn't make much
sense, does it?
But then look at the
alternative.
You built a device which
you're going to sell to
people, and which they're
going to use.
And you know they're only going
to use it three or four
year until something
better comes along.
But do you want to build in to
everything you're doing the
idea that it's going to be
obsolete in three years?
No.
You want to design this thing
so, in fact, it will work for
an essentially arbitrary
amount of time.
And therefore, you make a
mathematical model of it.
You look at what happens over
an infinite span of time.
So whenever we get into
mathematics, we always go to
an infinite number of
things rather than a
finite number of things.
Now, discrete stochastic
processes are those where the
random variables are
discrete in time.
Namely, a finite number
of possible outcomes
from each of them.
Or the set of possible sample
values is discrete.
What does that mean?
It doesn't mean a whole lot when
you really start asking
detailed questions about this.
What it means is, I want to talk
about a particular kind
of stochastic processes.
And it's a class of processes
which will be more than we can
deal with in one term.
And I want to exclude certain
processes, like noise
processes, because we don't have
time to do both of them.
So don't worry too much about
exactly what a discrete
stochastic process is.
It's whatever we want to call
it when we deal with it.
Oops.
Oh, where am I?
Oh, I wanted to talk about the
different processes we're
going to study.
The first kind of process
is what we
call a counting process.
The sample points in the
process-- remember, a sample
point specifies everything
about an experiment.
It tells you every
little detail.
And the sample points here
in counting processes are
sequences of arrivals.
This is a very useful idea in
dealing with queuing systems
because queuing systems
have arrivals.
They have departures.
They have rules for how the
arrivals get processed before
they get spit out.
And a big part of that is
studying first the arrival
process, then we study the
departure process.
We study how to put
them together.
And when we get to chapter 2 of
the notes, we're going to
be studying Poisson processes,
which are in a sense, the
perfect discrete stochastic
process.
It's like coin tossing
in probability.
Everything that might
be true with a
Poisson process is true.
The only things that aren't
true are the things that
obviously can't be true.
And we'll find out why
that is and how that
works a little later.
We're then going to
study renewal
processes in chapter 4.
We're going to put Markov
chains in between.
And you'll see why
when we do it.
And renewal processes are a more
complicated kind of thing
than Poisson processes.
And there's no point confusing
you at this point saying what
the difference is, so I won't.
Markov processes
are processes.
In other words, the sequences
in time of things where what
happens in the future depends
on what happens in the past,
only through the state
at the present.
In other words, if you can
specify the state in the
present, you can forget about
everything in the past.
If you have those kinds of
processes around, you don't
have to study history at all,
which would be very nice.
But unfortunately, not all
processes behave that way.
When you do the modeling to try
to find out what the state
is, which is what you have to
know at the present, you find
out there's a lot of
history involved.
OK, finally, we're going to talk
about random wa;ls and
martingales.
I'm not going to even say
what a random walks or
a martingale is.
We will find out about that
soon enough, but I want to
tell you that's what's in
chapter 7 of the notes.
That's the last topic
we will deal with.
We'll study all sorts of
mixtures of these.
Things which involve a
little bit of each.
We'll start out working
on one thing and
we'll find out another.
One of these other topics is the
right way to look at it.
If you want to know more about
that, please go look at the
notes, and you'll find out
as much as you want.
But it's not appropriate to
talk about it right now.
OK, when, where, and
how is this useful?
You see, I'm almost at the
point where we'll start
actually talking about
real stuff.
And when I say real stuff, I
mean mathematical stuff, which
is not real stuff.
Broad answer--
probability in stochastic
processes are an important
adjunct to rational thought
about all human
and scientific endeavor.
That's a very strong
statement.
I happen to believe it.
You might not believe it.
And you're welcome to
not believe it.
It won't be on a quiz or
anything, believe me.
But almost anything you have to
deal with is dealing with
something in the future.
I mean, you have to plan for
things which are going to
happen in the future.
When you look at the future,
there's a lot of uncertainty
involved with it.
One of the ways is dealing
with uncertainty.
And probably the only scientific
way of dealing with
uncertainty is through
the mechanism
of probability models.
So anything you want to deal
with, which is important,
you're probably better off
knowing something about
probability than not.
A narrow answer is probability
in stochastic processes are
essential components of
the following areas.
Now, I must confess I made up
this list in about 10 minutes
without thinking about
it very seriously.
And these things are related
to each other.
Some of them are parts
of others.
Let me read them.
Communication systems
and networks.
That's where I got involved
in this question, and very
important there.
Computer systems.
I also got involved in it
because of computer systems.
Queuing in all areas.
Well, I got involved in queuing
because of being
interested in networks.
risk management in all areas.
I got interested in that because
I started to get
disturbed about civilization
destroying itself because
people who have a great deal of
power don't know anything
about taking risks.
OK, catastrophe management.
How do you prevent oil spills
and things like that?
How do you prevent nuclear
plants from going off?
weapons from falling in the
hands of the wrong people?
These again, are probability
issues.
These are important probability
issues because
most people don't regard them
as probability issues.
If you say there is one chance
in a billion that something
will happen, 3/4 of the
population will say, that's
not acceptable.
I don't want any risk.
And these people are fools.
But unfortunately, these fools
outnumber those of us who have
studied these issues.
So we have to deal with it.
We have to understand
it if nothing else.
OK, failures in all
types of systems--
operations research, biology,
medicine, optical systems, and
control system.
Name your own favorite thing.
You can put it all in.
Probability gets used
everywhere.
OK, let's go to the axioms.
Probability models have three
components to them.
There's a sample space.
Now, here we're in mathematics
again.
The sample space is just
a set of things.
You don't have to be at all
specific about what those
things are.
I mean, at this point we're
right in to set theory, which
is the most basic part
of mathematics again.
And a set contains elements.
And that's what we're
talking about here.
So there's a sample space.
There are the elements
in that sample space.
There's also a collection
of things called events.
Now, the events are subsets
of the sample space.
And if you're dealing with a
finite set of things, there's
no reason why the events should
not be all subsets of
that countable collection
of things.
If you have a deck of cards,
there are 52 factorial ways of
arranging the cards in
that deck of cards.
Very large number.
But when you talk about subsets
of that, you might as
well talk about all combinations
of those
configurations of the deck.
You can talk about, what's the
probability that the first
five cards in that deck happen
to contain 4 aces?
That's an easy thing
to compute.
I'm sure you've all computed
it at some point or other.
Those who like to play poker,
of course do this.
It's fun.
But it's a straightforward
problem.
When you have these countable
sets of things, there's no
reason at all for not having the
set of events consist of
all possible subsets.
Well, people believed that
for a long time.
One of the things that forced
Kolmogorov to start dealing
with these axioms was the
realization that when you had
much more complicated sets,
where in fact you had the set
of real numbers as possible
outcomes, or sequences of
things which go from 0 to
infinity, and all of these
sets, which are uncountable,
you really can't make sense
out of probability models where
all subsets of sample
points are called events.
So in terms of measure theory,
you're forced to restrict the
set of things you call events.
Now, we're not going to
deal with measure
theory in this subject.
But every once in a while, we
will have to mention it
because the reason why a lot of
things are the way they are
is because of measure theory.
So you'll have to be at
least conscious of it.
If you really want to be
serious, as far as your study
of mathematical probability
theory, you really have to
take a course in measure
theory at some point.
But you don't have
to do it now.
In fact, I would almost urge
most of you not to do it now.
Because once you get all the
way into measure theory,
you're so far into measure
theory that you can't come
back and think about real
problems anymore.
You're suddenly stuck in the
world of mathematics, which
happens to lots of people.
So anyway, some of you should
learn about all this
mathematics.
Some of you shouldn't.
Some of you should learn
about it later.
So you can do whatever
you want.
OK, the axioms about events
is that if you
have a set of events.
In other words, a set of
subsets, and it's a countable
set, then the union
of all of those--
the union from n equals
1 to infinity of a sub
n is also an event.
I've gone for 50 minutes
and nobody has
asked a question yet.
Who has a question?
Who thinks that all of
this is nonsense?
How many of you?
I do.
OK, I'll come back in
another 10 minutes.
And if nobody has a question
by then, I'm just going to
stop and wait.
OK, so anyway.
If you look at a union
of events.
Now, remember, that an event
is a subset of points.
We're just talking about
set theory now.
So the union of this
union here--
excuse me.
This union here is A1, all the
points in A1, and all the
points in A2, and all the points
in A3, all the way up
to infinity.
That's what we're talking
about here.
And one of the axioms of
probability theory is that if
each of these things are events,
then this union is
also an event.
That's just an axiom.
You can't define events
if that's not true.
And if you try to define events
where this isn't true,
you eventually come into the
most god awful problems you
might imagine.
And suddenly, nothing
make sense anymore.
Most of the time when we define
a set of events in a
probability model, each
singleton event--
namely, each single point has
a set, which contains only
that element, is taken
as an event.
There's no real reason
to not do that.
If you don't do that, you might
as well just put those
points together and not regard
them as separate points.
We will see an example in a
little bit where, in fact, you
might want to do that.
But let's hold that off
for a little bit.
OK, not all subsets
need to be events.
Usually, each sample point is
taken to be a singleton event.
And then non-events are
truly weird things.
I mean, as soon as you take
all sample points to be
events, all countable unions of
sample points are events.
And then intersections of events
are events, and so
forth, and so forth,
and so forth.
So most things are events.
And just because of measure
theory, you can't make all
things events.
And I'm not going to give you
any example of that because
examples are horrendous.
OK, the empty set has
to be an event.
Why does the empty set
have to be an event.
If we're going to believe
these axioms--
I'm in a real bind here because
every one of you
people has seen these
axioms before.
And you've all gone on and said,
I can get an A in any
probability class in the world
without having any idea of
what these axioms
are all about.
And therefore, it's
unimportant.
So you see something
that says, the
empty set is an event.
And you say, well, of
course that has
nothing to do with anything.
Why should I worry about whether
the empty set is an
event or not?
The empty set can't happen,
so how can it be an event?
Well, because of these axioms,
it has to be an event.
The axioms say that if A is an
event, and that's the whole
sample space, then the
complement has
to be an event also.
So that says that the empty
set has to be an event.
And that just follows
from the axioms.
If all sample points are
singleton events, then all
finite and countable
sets are events.
And finally, deMorgan's law.
Is there anyone who isn't
familiar with deMorgan's law?
Anyone who hasn't seen
even that small
amount of set theory?
If not, look it up on--
what's the name of
the computer--
Wikipedia.
Most of you will think
that things on
Wikipedia are not reliable.
Strangely enough, in terms of
probability theory and a lot
of mathematics, Wikipedia does
things a whole lot better than
most textbooks do.
So any time you're unfamiliar
with what a word means or
something, you can look
it up in your
old probability textbook.
If you've used [INAUDIBLE]
and [INAUDIBLE], you will
probably find the
right answer there.
Other textbooks, maybe
the right answer.
Wikipedia's more reliable
than most of them.
And it's also clearer
So I highly recommend using
Wikipedia whenever you get
totally confused by something.
OK, so probability measure
and events satisfies
the following axioms.
We've said what things
are events.
The only things that have
probabilities are events.
So the entire set has
a probability.
When you do the experiment,
something has to happen.
So one of the sample
points occurs.
That's the whole idea
of probability.
And therefore, omega
has probability 1.
Capital Omega.
If A is an event, then the
probability of A has to be
greater than or equal to 0.
You can probably see without too
much trouble why it has to
be less than or equal
to 1 also.
But that's not one
of the axioms.
You see, when you state a set of
axioms for something, you'd
like to use the minimum set of
axioms you can, so that you
don't have to verify too many
things before you say, yes,
this satisfies all the axioms.
So the second one is the
probability of A has to be
greater than or equal to 0.
The third one says that if you
have a sequence of disjoint
events, incidentally when I say
a sequence, I will almost
always mean a countably
infinite sequence--
A1, A2, A3, all the way up.
If I'm talking about what
most of you would
call a finite sequence--
and I like the word "finite
sequence," but I like to be
able to talk about sequences.
I'm talking about a finite
sequence I will usually call
it an n-tuple of random
variables or
an n-tuple of things.
So sequence really means you
go the whole way out.
OK, if A1, A2, all the way
up are disjoint events--
disjoint.
Disjoint means if omega is only
in one, it can't be in
any of the others.
Then the probability of this
countable union is going to be
equal to the sum of the
probabilities of the
individual event.
Anyone who has ever done a
probability problem knows all
of these things.
The only thing you don't know
and you probably haven't
thought about is why
everything else
follows from this.
But this is the whole
mathematical theory.
Why should we study
it anymore?
We're done.
We have the axioms.
Everything else follows, it's
just a matter of computation.
Just sit down and do it.
Not quite that simple.
Anyway, a few consequences of
the probability of the empty
set is 0, which says when you
do an experiment something's
going to happen.
And therefore, the probability
that nothing happens is 0
because that's what
the model says.
The probability of the
complement of an event is 1
minus the probability
of that event.
Which, in fact, is what's says
that all events have to have
probabilities less than
or equal to 1.
And if the event A is contained
in the event B--
remember when we talk about
events, we're talking about
two different things,
both simultaneously.
One of them is this beautiful
idea with measure theory
worked into it and
everything else.
And the other is just a simple
set theoretic idea.
And all we need to be
familiar with is a
set theoretical idea.
Within that set theoretical
idea, A contained in B means
that every sample point that's
in A is also in B. It means
that when you do an experiment,
and the event A
occurs, the event B has to
occur because one of the
things that compose
A has to occur.
And that thing has to be in B
because A is contained in B.
So the probability of A has to
be less than or equal to the
probability of B. That has to
be less than or equal to 1.
These are things you all know.
Another consequence is
the union bound.
Many of you have probably
seen the union bound.
We will use it probably almost
every day in this course.
So it's good to have that as one
of the things you remember
at the highest level.
If you have a set of events--
A1, A2, and so forth--
the probability of
that union--
namely, the event that consists
of all of them--
is less than or equal to the
sum of the individual event
probabilities.
I give a little proof here for
just two events, A1 and A2.
So you see why this is true.
I hope you can extend
this to 3 and 4.
I can't draw a picture of
it very easily for 3
and 4 and so forth.
But here's the event A1.
Here's the event A2.
Visualize this as a set of
sample points, which are just
in the two-dimensional
space here.
So all these points
here are in A1.
All these points are in A2.
This set of points here
are the points that
are in A1 and A2.
I will use just writing things
next to each other to mean
intersection.
And sometimes I'll use a big
cap to main intersection.
So all of these things are
both in A1 and A2.
This is A2, but not A1.
So the probability of this whole
event, A1 union A2, is
the probability of this thing
and this thing together.
So it's the probability
of this plus the
probability of this.
The probability of this is less
than the probability of
A2 because this is contained
in that whole rectangle.
And therefore, the probability
of the union of A1 and A2 is
less than or equal to the
probability of A1 plus
probability of A2.
Now, the classy way to extend
this to a countably infinite
set is to use induction.
And I leave that as something
that you can all play with
some time when it's not between
9:30 and 11:00 in the
morning and you're struggling
to stay awake.
And if you don't want to do that
on your own, you can look
at it in the notes.
OK, these axioms look
ho-hum to you.
And you've always ignored them
before, and you think you're
going to be able to
ignore them now.
Partly you can, but partly you
can't because every once in a
while we'll start doing things
where you really need to
understand what the
axioms say.
OK, one other thing which you
might not have noticed.
When you studied elementary
probability, wherever you
studied it, what do you spend
most of your time doing?
You spent most of your time
talking about random variables
and talking about
expectations.
The axioms don't have random
variables in them.
They don't have expectations
in them.
All they have in them
is events and
probabilities of events.
So these axioms say that the
really important things in
probability are the events and
the probabilities of events.
And the random variables and the
expectations are derived
quantities, which we'll now
start to talk about.
OK, so we're now down to
independent events and
experiments.
Two events, A1 and A2, are
independent if the probability
of the two of them is equal
to the product of their
probabilities.
You've all seen this.
I'm sure you've all seen it.
If you haven't at least seen it,
you probably shouldn't be
in this class because even
though the text does
everything in detail that has to
be done, you need to have a
little bit of insight from
having dealt with these
subjects before.
If you don't have that, you're
just going to get lost very,
very quickly.
So the probability is the
intersection of the event A1
and A2 is the product
of the two.
Now, in other words, you have
a red die and a white die.
You flip the dice, what's the
probability that you get a 1
for the red die and a
1 for the white die?
Well, the probability you get
a 1 for the red die is 1/6.
Just by symmetry, there are only
6 possible things that
can happen.
Probability of white
die comes up as 1.
Probability is 1/6 for that.
And the probability of the two
things, they're independent.
There's a sense of real-world
independence and probability
theory independence.
Real-world independence says the
two things are isolated,
they don't interfere
with each other.
Probability theory says just
by definition, well, the
real-world idea of them not
interfering with each other
should say--
and I'm waving my hands here
because this is so elementary,
you all know it.
And I would bore you if I
talked about it more.
But I probably should
talk about it, but
I'm not going to.
Anyway, this is the definition
of independence.
If you don't have any idea of
how this corresponds to being
unconnected in the real-world,
then go to Wikipedia.
Read the notes.
Well, you should read
the notes anyway.
I hope you will read the notes
because I'm not going to say
everything in class that
needs to be said.
And you will get a better
feeling for it.
Now, here's something
important.
Given two probability models,
a combined model can be
defined in which, first, the
sample space, omega, is the
Cartesian product of omega
1 and omega 2.
Namely, it's the Cartesian
product of
the two sample spaces.
Think of rolling the red
die and the white die.
Rolling a red die is
an experiment.
There are 6 possible
outcomes, a 1 to 6.
Rolled a white die, there
are 6 possible
outcomes, a 1 to a 6.
You roll the two dice together,
and you really need
to have some way of
putting these
two experiments together.
How do you put them together?
You talk about the outcome for
the two dice, number for one
and number for the other.
The Cartesian product simply
means you have the set made up
of 1 to 6 Cartesian product
with 1 to 6.
So you have 36 possibilities.
It's an interesting thing,
which comes from
Kolmogorov's axioms.
That, in fact, you can take in
any two probability models for
two different experiments.
You can take this Cartesian
product of sample points.
You can assume that what happens
here is independent of
what happens here.
And when you do this, you will,
in fact, get something
for the two experiments put
together which satisfies
Kolmogorov's axioms.
That is neither trivial nor
very hard to prove.
I mean, for the case of two
dice, you can see it almost
immediately.
I mean, you see what the
sample space is.
It's this Cartesian product.
And you see what the
probabilities have to be
because the probability of, say,
1 and 2 for the red die
and 1 and 2 for the white
is 2, 6 times 2, 6.
So with probability 1/9, you're
going to get a 1 and a
2 combined with a 1 and a 2.
I'm going to talk a little
bit later about something
that you all know.
What happens if you roll
two white dice?
This is something you all ought
to think about a little
bit because it really isn't
as simple as it sounds.
If you roll two dice, what's
the probability that you'll
get a 1 and a 2?
And how can you justify that?
First, what's a sample space
when you roll two white dice?
Well, if you look at the
possible things that might
happen, you can get 1, 1; 2,
2; 3, 3; 4, 4; 5, 5; 6, 6.
You can also get 1, 2 or 2, 1.
But you can't tell them apart,
so there's one sample point,
you might say, which
is 1, 2, and 2, 1.
Another sample point which is
2, 3; 3, 2, and so forth.
If you count them up, there are
21 separate sample points
that you might have.
And when you look at what the
probabilities ought to be, the
probabilities of the
pairs are 136 each.
And the probabilities of the
I J, where I is unequal
to J is 1/18 each.
That's awful.
So what do you do?
When you're rolling two dice,
you do the same thing that
everybody else does.
You say, well, even though it's
two white dice, I'm going
to think of it as if it's a
white die and a red die.
I'm going to think of it as if
the two are indistinguishable.
My sample space is going to be
these 36 different things.
I will never be able
to distinguish a
1, 2 from a 2, 1.
But I don't care because
I now know the
probability of each of them.
What I'm trying to say by this,
is this a very, very
trivial example of where you
really have to think through
the question of what kind of
mathematical model do you want
of the most simple situation
you can think of almost.
When you combine two different
experiments together and you
lose distinguishability,
then what do you do?
Well, the sensible thing to
do is assume that the
distinguishability is still
there, but it's not
observable.
But that makes it hard to make
a correspondence between the
real world and the probability
world.
So we'll come back
to that later.
But for the most part, you don't
have to worry about it
because this is something
you've dealt
with all of your lives.
I mean, you've done probability
problems with dice.
You've done probability problems
with all sorts of
other things where things are
indistinguishable from each other.
And after doing a few of these
problems, you are used to
being schizophrenic about it.
And on one hand, thinking
that these things are
distinguishable to figure
out what all the
probabilities are.
And then you go back to saying,
well, they aren't
really distinguishable, and
you find the right answer.
So you don't have to
worry about it.
All I'm trying to say here is
that you should understand it.
Because when you get the
complicated situations, this
is one of the main things which
will cause confusion.
It's one of the main things
where people write papers and
other people say that paper is
wrong because they're both
thinking of different
models for it.
Important thing is if you
satisfy Kolmogorov's axioms in
each of a set of models, and
most important thing is where
each of these models are
exactly the same.
And then you make them each
independent of each other,
Kolmogorov's axioms are going
to be satisfied for the
combination, as well as
the individual model.
Why do I care about that?
Because we're studying
stochastic processes.
We're studying an infinite
sequence of random variables.
And I don't want to generate a
complete probability model for
an infinite set of random
variables every time I talk
about an infinite set
of random variables.
If I'm talking about an infinite
sequence of flipping
a coin, I want to do what you
do, which is say, for each
coin, the coin is equiprobably
a head or a tail.
And the coin tosses are
independent of each other.
And I want to know that I can go
from that to thinking about
this sequence.
Strange things will happen
in these sequences when
we go to the limit.
But still, we don't want to have
to worry about a model
for the whole infinite
sequence.
So that's one of the things
we should deal with.
Finally, random variables.
Definition.
Three years ago, I taught this
course and I asked people to
write down definition of what
a random variable was.
And almost no one really had
any idea of what it was.
They said it was something
that had a probability
density, or something that had
a probability mass function,
or something that had a
distribution function, or
something like that.
What it is, if you want to get
a definition which fits in
with the axioms, the only thing
we know from the axioms
is there's a sample space.
There are events and there
are probabilities.
So a random variable, what it
really is, is it's a function
from the set of sample points
to the set of real values.
And as you get into this, you
will realize that the set of
real values does not
include minus
infinity or plus infinity.
It says that every sample
point gets mapped into a
finite value.
This happens, of course,
when you flip a coin.
Well, flipping a coin,
the outcome is
not a random variable.
But you'd like to make it a
random variable, so you say,
OK, I'm going to model
tails as 0 and heads
as 1, or vice versa.
And then what happens?
Your model for coin tossing,
a sequence of coin tosses
becomes the same as your
model for data.
So that what you know about coin
tossing, you can apply to
data compression.
You see, when you think about
these things mathematically,
then you can make all sorts
of connections you
couldn't make otherwise.
So random variables have to
satisfy the constraint that--
they have to satisfy the
constraint that the set of
sample points, such that x, x
of omega, which is a real
number, is less than or equal
to some given real number.
That this set has
to be an event.
Because those are the only
things that have
probabilities.
So if we want to be able to talk
about the probabilities
of these random variables lying
in certain ranges, or
things like this, or having
PMFs, or anything that you
like to do, you need this
constraint on it.
It's an event for all A in
the set of real numbers.
Also, if this set
of things here
are each random variables.
In other words, if each of them
are functions from the
sample space to the real line,
then the set of omega such
that x1 of omega is less than
or equal to A1, up to An of
omega is less than or equal
to A n is an event also.
You might recognize this as the
distribution function, the
joint distribution function
for n random variables.
You might recognize this as
the distribution function
evaluated at A for a single
random variable.
So you define a random
variable.
And what we're doing here is--
it's kind of funny because we
already have these axioms.
But now when we want to define
things in the context of these
axioms, we need extra things
in the definitions.
This is a distribution function,
a distribution
function of the random variable
x is the probability
that the random variable x is
less than or equal to x, which
means that x is a mapping from
omega into real numbers.
It says that with this mapping
here, you're mapping this
whole sample space into
the real line.
Some omegas get mapped into
things less than or equal to a
real number x.
Some of them get mapped into
things greater than
the real number x.
And the set that gets mapped
into something less than or
equal to x, according to the
definition of a random
variable, has to be an event.
Therefore, it has to
have a probability.
And these probabilities
increase as we go.
It is totally immaterial for all
purposes whether we have a
less than or equal to here
or a less than here.
And everyone follows the
convention of using a less
than or equal to here rather
than a less than here.
The importance of that is
that when you look at a
distribution function,
the distribution
function often has jumps.
And the distribution will have
a jump whenever there's a
nonzero probability that the
random variable takes on a
particular value x here.
It takes on this particular
value with something more than
probabilities here.
If you have a probability
density for a random variable,
this curve just moves
up continuously.
And the derivative
of this curve is
the probability density.
If you have a probability mass
function, this is a staircase
type of function.
Because of the fact that we
define the distribution
function with a less than or
equal to rather than a less
than means that in every one of
these jumps, the value here
is the upper value
of the jump.
Value here is the upper value
of the jump, and so forth.
Now, I'm going to--
I've already said
half of this.
Affects maps only until finite
or countable set of values.
It's discrete.
And it has a probability
mass function--
this notation.
If the derivative exists, then
you say that the random
variable is continuous
and it has a density.
And most problems that you do in
probability theory, you're
dealing with random variables.
And they either have a
probability mass function if
they're discrete or they have
a density if they're
continuous.
And this is just saying some
things are one way, some
things are the other way.
And some things are neither.
And we'll see lots of things
that are neither.
And you need the distribution
function to talk about things
that are neither.
We will find that the
distribution function, which
you've hardly ever used in the
past, is extraordinarily
important, both for theoretical
purposes and for
other purposes.
You really need that as a way
of solving problems, as well
as keeping yourself
out of trouble.
For every random variable, the
distribution function exists.
Why?
Anybody know why this
has to exist for
every random variable?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Because
the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Because we insisted
that it did.
Namely, we insisted that this
event actually was an event
for all little x.
That's part of the definition.
So, in fact, when you do these
things a little more carefully
than you might be used to, the
definition implies that the
distribution function
always exists.
As a more real-world kind of
argument, we now have a way of
dealing with things that are
discrete, and continuous, and
mixed continuous and discrete,
and anything else that you
might think of because the
definition restricts it.
Now, one other thing.
How do I know that
this starts at 0?
That's a more complicated
thing.
And I'm not even going
to do it in detail.
But since every omega maps
into a finite number, you
can't have a jump down here
at minus infinity.
And you can't have a jump
here at plus infinity.
Because omegas don't
map into plus
infinity or minus infinity.
So you have to start
down here at 0.
You have to climb
up here to 1.
You might never reach 1.
You might reach it only as a
limit, but you have to reach
it as a limit.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: In the first
paragraph, [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: If we have a sequence
of [INAUDIBLE], yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You are
probably right.
Yes.
Well, I don't know I don't
think about that one.
I don't think you're right,
but we can argue about it.
But anyway, this has
to start at 0.
It has to go up to 1.
OK, we did this.
Now, I'm going to go through a
theoretical nitpick for the
last five minutes
of the class.
Anyone who doesn't like
theoretical nitpicks, you're
welcome to either go to sleep
for five minutes, or you're
welcome to go out and get a cup
of coffee, or whatever you
want to do.
I will do this to you
occasionally.
And I realize it's almost
torture for some of you,
because I want to get you used
to thinking about how
relatively obvious things
actually get proven.
I want to increase your ability
to prove things.
The general statement about
proving things, or at least
the way I prove things, is not
the way most mathematicians
prove things.
Most mathematicians prove things
by starting out with
axioms and going step by step
until they get to what they're
trying to prove.
Now, every time I talk to a good
mathematician, I find out
that's what they write down when
they prove something, but
that's not the way they
think about it at all.
All of us-- engineers,
businesspeople, everyone--
thinks about problems
in a different way.
If we're trying to prove
something, we first give a
really half-assed proof of it.
And after we do that, we look
at it and we say, well, I
don't see why this is true and
I don't see why that's true.
And then you go back and you
patch these things up.
And then after you patch
things up, it
starts to look ugly.
So you go back and do
it a nicer way.
And you go back and forth and
back and forth and back and
forth, using both contradiction
and implication.
You use both of them.
Now, when you're proving things
in this class, I don't
care whether you make it look
like you're a formal
mathematician or not.
I would just assume you didn't
pretend you were a formal
mathematician.
I would like to see you prove
things in such a way that it
is at least difficult to poke
a hole in your argument.
In other words, I would like you
to give an argument which
you've thought about enough
that there aren't obvious
counter examples to it.
And if you learn to do that,
you're well on your way to
learning to use this theory in
a way where you can actually
come up with correct answer.
And in fact, I'm not going to go
through this proof at all.
And I don't think I
really wanted to.
I just did it because--
well, I think it's something
you ought to read.
It is important to learn to
prove things because when you
get to complicated systems,
you cannot see your way
through them intuitively.
And if you can't see your way
through it intuitively, you
need to understand something
about how to prove things, and
you need to put all the
techniques of proving things
that you learned together with
all the techniques that you've
learned for doing things
intuitively.
And you need to know how
to put them together.
If you're stuck dealing only
with things that are
intuitive, or things that you
learned in high school like
calculus, then you really can't
deal with complicated
systems very well.
OK, I'm going to end
at that point.
You can read this theoretical
nitpick if you want,
and play with it.
And we'll go on next time.